Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Morning, Ruffians!
Thank you for waking up and joining us today for our 56th episode!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Oh, maybe Ruffians, is this your first time joining us today?
Maybe not.
Maybe not!
But it is!
Wow, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
I see some Ruffians saying it's their first time.
Oh, oh, oh, oh?
And I know it's not.
Well, anyways, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, are you awake?
Why are you so fluffy and fuzzy?
Are you still fuzzy in bed?
Or sleepy?
Wake up!
It's time to wake up!
I think one Ruffian spotted.
Let's see.
Let's see where he is this time.
De-den!
That's a very good snowman.
The best one!
It's so cute!
Making a bad situation into something good.
You know, we're glad you were able to save the snow day before Pero maybe turned it into a bit of a bad one.
But you know, I think that's a textbook snowman right there.
Yeah!
Perfect.
You know, aside from Pero being trapped in the lower body, but... Aside from that, yeah.
But it looks good despite everything.
It's good, just good.
It looks perfect.
Yes, perfect.
No rocks, no leaves.
Nice snow.
But I guess Pero must be pretty weak.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, maybe we should remember that for the future.
Could be handy!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the handy tip.
Actually now I'm looking at the snowman's nose and I'm starting to feel a little bit hungry.
Looks pretty yummy, no?
Carrot.
Good breakfast snack.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians!
Something very happy happened!
We can't really believe it, but Ruffians!
Our cover of Cute no Kanojo has hit 500,000 views!
BAU BAU!
How did that happen?
I feel like we were just celebrating the last laughing, but thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your support!
Actually, we had something that we wanted to share with you.
BAU BAU!
We'll see.
And also speaking of 500,000 milestone, Bijou!
hololive's shining gem Bijou Koseki Bijou has hit 500,000 subscribers on YouTube!
500,000 pebbles!
That's a lot of pebbles.
Almost enough for a driveway.
Congratulations, Biboo!
Biboo!
You know, she's such a hard worker.
Silly and cute.
We're very happy for her.
We're happy that we're all so close and such a strong team all together with all of Advent.
We can't wait to reach even more milestones together.
Congratulations!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations.
Topic of more Advent news.
Nerissa.
Nerissa!
She just announced her newest song cover of S.O.S.
from Idolmaster, Shiny Colors!
Yeah, you know Ruffians, we actually have a song cover.
We're really excited because we really, really like this song from before.
So we're excited to hear when it comes out on December 15th at 4.45pm PT.
Yeah, okay.
Very important time.
It's really before our weekly Advent Club, okay?
So don't forget, okay?
Don't forget, okay?
But you know, Nerissa's such an amazing singer.
And we know that she really likes Idolmaster too.
But you know, we can't really say that we've heard her sing a super cute idol song so far or anything like that.
So, we're really looking forward to it!
Yeah, she's got quite the voice.
It's gonna be cute.
You liked your calendar?
Good, good.
Wow, you know, another Nerissa cover.
I don't know, I feel like we're so lucky.
So many covers, but we're always really looking forward to Nerissa's music and seeing what she does next.
So vote for her!
Make it on your calendar!
Please make sure to check it out, okay?
BAU BAU!
And more happiness, but
FUWAMOCO, we have something exciting coming up!
It was announced that us, FUWAMOCO, will be heading over to Malaysia to appear at ComicFest!
It's gonna be happening in Kuala Lumpur for the first time ever!
BAU BAU!
See us!
As for Ruffians who are a bit further away and can't make it to the event,
It's too bad, but this time you won't be able to join us virtually like how things were like with our last clone appearance.
You know, it was a special case and we were really lucky.
But we're gonna do our best!
And hopefully we'll be able to meet some new Ruffians there too!
We'll do our best, shall we?
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
It's too bad.
Also, I had a bit of a scoop.
A scoop!
Ruffians, thank you for reporting directly back to us with your scoops.
Because there was something, something that happened.
And actually, I... I need to sneeze!
It's painful!
That's not the scoop, Moco-chan.
Wow!
You know, Biboo... Biboo, she's on a bit of a roll recently.
A bit of a roll.
Yeah, and she's been playing Super Mario RPG's remake too, right?
Wow... As it turns out... You know, apparently, Biboo also makes a very good sword.
You know, just like Fuwawa happens to be.
Right?
Yeah!
Well, she was showing off her Toad voice to everyone during the stream.
You know which sort of means that Advent officially has two Toad voice appreciators or actors.
Out of all five of us!
Yeah!
You know, but I guess we can't say about Nerissa and Shiori.
We're not sure of the quality of their Toad voice yet.
But Moco-chan's a no.
Yeah!
Moco-chan, since you're no good at it... Who do you think is better, me or Biboo?
I think you're both the same but different toads.
Wait, so I'm like a blue toad and Biboo's like a purple toad?
Yeah.
We'll have to have a toad off later.
Toad off!
BAU BAU!
What?
What do you mean no toad off?
Wow, Ruffians!
There's also something that we noticed recently.
We wanted to say a bit of a thank you.
You know, there's a lot of silly moments in our streams, right?
So...
Also, really thankful for the clippers!
The clippers that, you know, they kinda cut things up a little bit.
And they help us share those moments with lots of Ruffians so that we can protect their smiles a bit easier throughout their busy days.
You know, sometimes there's some, uh...
Pretty.
Silly clips.
But you know, there are also some very thoughtful clips out there too, you know?
Like, the other day during our Yuru hololive Mario Kart stream, with our senpai, you know, we were having some pretty bad technical issues that we just couldn't fix, and you know, it was pretty upsetting for us.
But,
You know, thankfully, we noticed that some Clippers, you know, they helped out.
And they tried to make it look like there wasn't any technical issues or problems during their clips from those moments.
So, we were really happy.
It was very touching.
So nice of my Ruffians.
Thank you so much for being kind and taking the extra step to fix a bit of a frustrating moment for us.
We really appreciate it.
We're really thankful too.
Thank you so much.
Let's continue to put lots of smiles.
BAU BAU!
That's so nice of you.
Wow.
Speaking of nice and happy things.
Ruffians!
Wow.
FUWAMOCO, we've been trying extra hard recently.
Extra hard.
And I think, I don't know, maybe at least it feels like this is the first time in a while now.
Don't say that.
But, Ruffians.
There's been no misunderstandings!
BAU BAU!
No misunderstandings, not a single one!
We did it!
You know, even though we had the Yuru Haru Mario Kart Club with our senpai.
Yeah.
No misunderstandings.
Nothing.
Definitely nothing.
BAU BAU!
We will continue to do our best to have no misunderstandings without this senpai.
For the rest of the month?
The rest of the year!
The rest of the year, I like that.
Oh, you think we can do it for the rest of the year, Ruffians?
I think we can do it, Moco-chan.
Yeah.
We're strong.
BAU BAU!
Happy.
Well, Moco-chan.
You know... What?
Ruffians!
This Wednesday, a bad day of the week.
Typically a bad day.
Mainly for Fuwawa, it's a bad day of the week.
Okay.
But, in case I can make you feel a bit, a bit happier.
Ruffians!
I wanted to say something!
So, you better listen up, okay?
Do you know what time this is?
Do you know what this is?
This here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
You, Ruffians!
No, it's almost the end of the year.
I know it can be exciting!
You know, looking forward to holidays and food and fun times!
But!
I also know that it can be a bit rough and that things might not be like that sometimes.
That this is the time of the year where it's easy to feel the pressure and stress from so many different areas!
So...
At the very least, this isn't the time for adding extra stress onto yourself.
Give yourself a break from it all!
You're doing your best just to put up with all the expectations on you, so don't put any more on yourself unnecessarily, okay?
You've done a good job this year.
You know it!
I know it!
You're doing your best to balance everything in your life, so keep on at it!
After all, life is just a silly journey that takes us a bunch of amazing places, even if we never expected it to end up like that.
So, don't worry about the small details, just enjoy the wonderful moments when you're in them, okay?
It's Chiyo, so make sure not to only keep your body warm, but also keep your heart warm and happy too, okay?
It's all gonna be okay!
Let's make it amazing together.
Got it!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
It's rough, right?
But we can do it, FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
With a little bit more pulp, let's go take a look at another pulp.
Because next we'll have the Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is...
De-den!
It's Gizmo!
Gizmo is tiny.
It's a chihuahua.
I'm a chihuahua!
I'm Gizmo!
But you know Gizmo's expression.
It sure looks like you woke him up from a good nap.
It does.
Well, how does Gizmo BAU BAU?
BAU BAU.
Really?
Gizmo's timing!
In this expression, this movement.
BAU BAU.
But normally, after he's awake.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
Gizmo.
Gizmo is as tiny as a gizmo.
Very cute!
BAU BAU!
De-den!
A bit of a vacation.
I don't know, you know, I've been seeing all the cold and snowy landscapes, so this is quite a bit different.
This is the exact opposite.
This looks hot!
Like the type of place Peru wants to be right now, hot.
I don't know why, but when I see a cactus, I feel like I want to hug it.
I don't know why.
Brain says no, heart says yes.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, please, good times.
Make sure you go on walks, especially even if it's cold outside.
It's good, you know, just getting some fresh air.
But please be safe.
And for the Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
It's almost time to start preparing for the next big holiday, Christmas.
To prepare, do you buy a real pine tree or an artificial tree?
Good question.
See, there are lots of trees in the northwest past.
So, as puppies, we always look forward to going out and finding a good tree together with Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy.
You know, the perfect tree.
And the color, good smell, and whether it's fluffy or fuzzy enough, always important.
You know, but also, always wanted to get the tallest tree possible!
Like, really!
It's okay, maybe.
Yeah, but it just doesn't smell right now.
Oh, well, you know.
It's how things are.
Maybe it's better that way.
BAU BAU!
Good luck, Ruffians, with all your holiday preparations, okay?
But, like Moco-chan said, don't worry too much about it.
Okay?
Good luck.
Don't get worked up unnecessarily, okay?
Wow, what do we have, Moco-chan?
Oh!
First, I want to say something.
Oh, first, what?
Thank you always for all your submissions, for sending us your questions, sharing us your doggies, and also thank you for your FUWAMOCO scoop too!
Please don't forget the hashtag FWMC scoop for the scoops, and the hashtag FWMCMORNING for your morning.
BAU BAU!
As for our next theme,
We have de-den!
We're gonna be playing Home Sweet Home on Biboo's channel!
Is Biboo in this photo?
Almost.
We're playing episode 2!
I know we finished the first game with Biboo back in October, but we left off on such a cliffhanger.
Okay, what's our wife's name?
Jennifer.
Ruffians, is that our wife's name?
Not Tina.
Tina?
Jane?
I don't know, but once we find her, we'll be able to find out what her name was again.
Yeah, once we find her.
Get our wife back.
BAU BAU!
After our schedule!
Ruffians, we have a lot of plans this week, but on Saturday, we're gonna be having our second unarchived Rock n' Rawr Party!
Yeah, the second ever!
Second ever, you know.
You know, it's kind of looking a bit fancy there.
Just maybe.
Please get ready to sing some very special holiday songs with us, okay, Ruffians?
Okay!
Don't miss it!
BAU BAU!
And that's just a little peek at what we have coming up.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Marine!
BAU BAU!
Bat Gamer!
Jacket!
BAU BAU!
Wizard Kid!
Wax.
BAU BAU!
Nubbin.
Rero.
BAU BAU!
Mimeicious.
Asteroids.
BAU BAU!
Voice-sama.
Jun.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!